the infinite game is not the absence of
finite games um
uh it's the the infinite game is the
context within which those finite games
exist
but if you're ignorant of the existence
of the infinite game then all you're
ever playing is finite
but you're in an infinite game and you
will do damage
you know jack welch once said long term
is simply a series of short term
no it's not absolutely it's not because
if all you do is play short short short
short short
eventually you create long term damage
you do damage to your culture you do
damage to your clients
you've you've put so many cheap
ingredients in your product you've
actually
you know destroyed the quality of your
product and eventually eventually it
catches up with you
um if all you're doing is playing finite
finite finite
um it's more efficient when it comes
from the top but of course it doesn't
have to come from the top
the tail can absolutely wag the dog and
i think middle management is the most
difficult job
in a company and it's off it's also the
place where the most change
and the most impact can happen i've met
so many fantastic senior leaders
who are infinite minded and long-term
focused on all the things
and then you get down to the front lines
and you're like it's a complete disaster
and so you ask your question
what's happening in the middle because
something's getting lost in translation
um
and being middle management is is the
most difficult job in the company
because you have to be able to play both
right
you because if you're if you're a gate
agent for an airline
you want them playing the finite game
you want them getting that plane to
leave on time
beginning middle and end on to the next
right but you want them to be aware of
the infinite game which is
treat customers well because we want
them to come back again like
there's another thing that happens after
this it's not just getting the plane off
on time
when you're the most senior leader you
want them playing predominantly an
infinite game thinking long term
advancing the vision
but you want them to be aware of the
finite because their decisions will
ripple down and have an impact in the
organization
if you're in the middle you have to be
able to translate and play both it is
the most difficult
which is why talking about the two types
of games and understanding
the game that you're in because you play
by the rules for the game that you're in
you don't always play finite you don't
always play infinite sometimes you have
to adjust
if you have a new business pitch there's
a beginning middle and end to that that
is finite
an election there's a beginning middle
and end to that governance is infinite
taking care of a customer is infinite
winning a customer is finite
right but there's a context and so yes
it's not about one or the other it's
about understanding the continuum
and understanding where we are in the
continuum and i think that
where senior management can help is
really helping middle management a
understand
that that the difficulty of their job
the transition they're in and trying to
give them as much context
and coaching as possible because most
things break in the middle